[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم بعدما الغى قاده
الانقلاب حزمه من الاتفاقات مع باريس
انتهاء سيران الاتفاق الذي ينظم الوجود
العسكري الفرنسي في النيجر اليوم محتاجون
يواصلون تظاهراتهم في اليمين للمطالبه
برحيل القوات الفرنسيه وقرار قضائي يؤيد
ترحيل سفير باريس
بعد تاكيدها الحصول على صواريخ بريطانيه
وفرنسيه بعيده المدى تعلن اختراق خط
الدفاع الاول للقوات الروسيه في زفروجيا
روسيا تنفي وتقول انها هاجمت بالمسيرات
منشات في ميناء
رفضا لقرارات وزير الامن الاسرائيلي
اعتمار بنكفير بحق الاسرى وعائلاتهم لجنه
الطوارئ العليا للحركه الاسيره تعلن ان
الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال سيشرعون في اضراب
مفتوح عن الطعام بدءا من الرابع عشر من
الشهر الجاري وذلك بعد حرمان عائلاتهم من
زياراتهم في السجون اضافه الى تشتيت قاده
الاسرى واصحاب المحكوميات العاليه
بتوزيعهم على السجون الاسرائيليه
بعد دير الزور واري في حلب الاشتباكات بين
مقاتلي العشائر العربيه وما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه تمتد الى رفيق الرقه
والحسكه ومسؤولون امريكيون يلتقون ممثلين
جانبين ويدعون الى وقف التصعيد الى اللقاء